hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast humans and fish to study
cellular mechanisms of neuromuscular
development I am Chris and present yo
blabbers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots for more
information please visit lab roots comm
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an education on what
web seminars and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Chiara Mancini dr. Nandini is a
human geneticist and cell biologist
whose laboratory focuses on the
molecular mechanisms of brain
development her group at the George
Washington University identified
disease-causing mutations and families
affected by brain malformations
intellectual disability in autism she
uses both zebrafish and mouse models to
study the cellular function of these
disease genes she obtained her
undergraduate degree in molecular
biology from the University of Pavia in
Italy a PhD in neurobiology and behavior
from Columbia University in New York
City and completed post doctoral
training in neurogenetics
at Boston Children's Hospital and
Harvard Medical School in Boston
she joined to see the GW
in 2013 I will now turn it over to dr.
Mancini for her presentation hello Thank
You Kristen for the introduction and
thank you to lab groups for giving me
the chance to tell everyone about what
my lab is doing our assistant said we do
use a combination of human genetics and
animal models to study the mechanisms of
neurodevelopmental disorders and today
in particular I will tell you about a
project focusing on your muscular
development using zebrafish as a model
so that is the big question
the big question we're trying to
understand is how does the brain develop
and how it goes from small vesicles
really early doing human gestation so
this beautiful complicated organ that
controls everything that we do in our
lives what my hunger story is trying to
figure out is what happens when there's
an Intel during development that affects
the developmental processes regulating
the brain causing either structural or
functional deficits structural deficits
are brain malformations where the grain
structure will be disrupted the
functional deficit could have a
relatively normal looking brain but
still have efficient functions such as
an intellectual disability and autism
spectrum disorder where cognitive
function and social function are
affected so how do we do that we start
from humans until we identify families
that have specific developmental
disorders that affect the brain and do
genetic studies to identify the genes
that are responsible then once we've
identified the genes which we know to be
essential for human development we try
to figure out why because they're being
perturbed causes disease which principal
goals 1 goal of course is to better
understand the phenotype of the patient
and so to understand what is happening
and
how the different organs that are sensor
affected and how the brain a brain
development is distrusted but also if 50
is referring the government they must be
incredibly important for that process
and so we really want to also define the
molecular mechanisms that they control
and that is the more essential more
basic function can I was talking about
today is one of the projects in the lab
that focuses on the role of
extracellular matrix in the
differentiation of neurons it's a cool
project because it uses both human
genetics so next-generation sequencing
the church state-of-the-art sequencing
technologies any people validation of
identified genes in zebrafish and to
basically figure out why the patient
where patient's phenotype is originating
from at the beginning of this project
was led by multiple students and text in
my lab society Costanza was now laughs
and she's in graduate school UCSC and
her problem which languages and
zebrafish facility penicillin allowed
and a very talented undergraduate Tabo
and ISA who is also moved on so why does
the cellular matrix so the extracellular
matrix is a very interesting structure
if this is the plasma membrane and the
cell membrane near for cellular matrix
is outside the cell and it is a meshwork
of proteins and polysaccharides
polysaccharides and our chains of sugars
that are also called glycans and this
structure is very complex it's very
difficult to tease out what all the
different components are and it was
originally thought to pretty much act as
glue so these are kind of my sites
really beautiful electron microscopy
image and yet the cellular matrix
supposed to hold is holding the
different muscle fibers in the in the
heart together
acting kind of like as a glue and that
was originally the idea well yet
cellular matrix was doing now I know
that
things are a lot more complex the pessoa
matrix in cm surrounds the narrows
throughout development and I became
interested in it actually when I was a
graduate student and I started doing
experiments on it and so here you can
see these on your novel progenitors from
the cerebellum we distained the shows
that there is extracellular matrix
surrounding all of these cells if you
look at a section of this of the mouse
brain you see a very very strong layer
of matrix at the very top this is the
basal lamina which is very important we
will see it on your own migration and
for brain integrity that is both types
of cellular matrix distributed across
different layer of the cortex this is a
particular kind of proteoglycan and so
the desert differential expression and
different stages of development and
different organizations pointed to the
fact that the ECM also has a functional
role for neural differentiation that
were actually trying to figure out so if
the CM is disrupted another support for
the fact that the ECM is important for
brain development is the fact that ECM
is disrupted you can have multiple types
of brain disorders so here I am
listening sharing some laminin and
collagen transmembrane proteins that is
integrates and disturb lichen and the
seven transmembrane domain protein
receptor GPI 56 and mutations in all of
these genes are indicated here cause
disruptions in brain development and so
you will have a normal grin to look at
the bottom you'll have a normal brain
and there on the left and then
disruptions of white matter with the
Nanyan alpha two mutations reduction in
organization of the brain GPI 56 and
very severe disruption ventricular
largely disruption in the cortex we are
particular commodities which are defects
in district writing so these just
membrane proteins are often like
oscillators and
said they have short sugar sequences
that regulates their interactions with
each other and control how they how they
formed or dances on your matrix in form
before the protein we're particularly
interested in is our position like in
mr. baiken is a two part is cleaved into
a data protein and an aqua protein and
the alpha protein is very heavily
glycosylated interacts with
intracellular compartments if a failure
matrix components such as laminin
through it's going case when these
interactions are disrupted that is when
you get disease and so these disorders
are called district election opposite
which is a very complicated name and it
basically means diseases caused by
defects in this provided what happens in
these disorders is actually across
multiple organs because mr. baiken has a
very important function in multiple
systems one of the primary deficits that
you see at the top is actually in the
muscle on the locket panel in the
district and by calculation you see the
district idea is by calculated around
the muscle fibers within the by the
human muscle biopsy it's by calculation
considered by conformation around the
muscle fibers and it's missing in the
patient in efficient biopsy almost
completely when that does deplete some
very severe muscular dystrophy then
usually present burns and so it's
congenital
that is one of the most severe forms of
muscular dystrophy that was ever been
identified in addition to that the loss
of this Iraq and reconciliation also
called with severe ocular defects
erectile development and also the
formation of interior chamber which is
the lens in the cornea on part of your
eye in very severe blame observations
and here you see one of the most severe
brain malformations we change the
cobblestone this assembly where the
coordinate is pretty much smooth the
ventricles are incredibly large and you
see
completely empty space that also the
brain stem and the cerebellum are
severely affected in addition you may
have read Aman formations so lots of
disregarded conformation effects
multiple tissues and what itself is that
this process is important in various
places in the body
so let's status of the brain when you
look at a brain with competence
especially on this destroyed property
you see this very characteristic
disruption that you see in the middle
where the white matter and the gray
banners there intermix there isn't a
clear definition and that is a very
severe neuronal migration deficit and
you'll see it also in the pathology on
the right where instead of having a nice
six reorganization of the cortex you
have this clumps of cells that are
sitting all over the place and so just
to recap on what happens when the court
develops you have a progenitor cell that
will that extend from the ventricle to
the pia that will generate new new cells
new neurons the Europe's will migrate
using the progenitors of scaffold and
they will organize and laminate the
cortex in this particular condition
you'll have a disruption in your
progenitor cell you have a disruption in
the basement membrane which is that very
thick layer or extracellular matrix that
I was telling you about at the very
beginning and so the anchoring of the
progenitor cells of the radial glial
into the basement membrane is disrupted
and the neurons don't migrate correctly
some of them older migrate so they'll go
above on the surface of the brain but
they will stay below in the white matter
let me go above in the surface of the
brain they form clumps of cells and
actually this is what gives the name of
the confirmation accomplished Wilma
successfully because when you look at
one of these grains upon autopsy you
basically see little pebbles of cells
sitting on top of the brain so one of
the problems with different analogies is
that yesterday
this is very very severe form that I
just told you about but they can also
cause a different range of phenotypes as
you can see here in the bottom the genes
that we have identified so far all the
explained forty to sixty percent of the
cases and most of them regulate - is
Rebecca under conservation bringing us
back to that mechanism that we were
talking about at the beginning the
problem is that it would be very hard to
diagnose one of these patients because
there's a lot of genes we don't know
whether one of the responsible genes is
going to be involved in this particular
case and the presentation of the brain
can vary and so you often have to test
every single one of the genes which can
be quite expensive when you only have a
50% hit rate so what you do when you
have to deal with a hair genius with a
genius disorder a lot of groups have
focused on families that are more
genetically informative so that you
don't need multiple families with the
same disease and you can actually just
focus on one individual family to try
and find out what is wrong with them
which will help you with bypassing
somebody heterogeneity and so to do that
you go the countries where there is a
higher incidence of consumer
inexperience which means first second or
third cousin marriages and this is a map
over to certain Americans happen around
the world their most frequent around the
world and the blue asterisks are where
some of our major collaborators are
located and where our families are
collected so why do we do this the
reason why we do this is that studies
family which has been family is like a
first cousin
Union allows us to use a genetic trick
so when do you have a conservative
family you expect the mutation to have
originated in the past from one of the
ancestors and would be this like little
cross from the orange chromosome
as the mutation passes along through the
different generations at some point you
will have two descendants of the person
with the original mutation that both
carry that chromosome they inherited
from their ancestors that one chromosome
is identical in cycle that one's DNA
region is identical and it will need
itself and it would be homozygous which
means that it would be the same reason
inherited from the mom in the dead from
a common ancestor and that will cause
the disease in one of the kids and so
what you do you focus on the regions of
homozygosity this is very helpful
because in a first cousin Union like
this around 6% of the genome is
predicted to be homozygous and so you
can actually remove the remaining 94
percent so let's see how we do this so
this is a family affected by Walker
Warburg syndrome which is the most
severe form of this of iconography has
congenital muscular dystrophy and that
very very severe called this rule is
successfully that I showed you at the
beginning their first cousin Union do we
have all the one child in the family who
is deceased and so we use a masking
method which is colic snip snip erase to
map the home of the gods in your hetero
zygosity across the entire genome if you
can see here in like gray black and
darker gray those are the chromosomes
and in blue above them are the regions
of homozygosity if I can draw your
attention for example the chromosome 8
where most of the chromosome is
homozygous
what we found in this family is that 9.6
percent of their kin was almost I guess
which in contrast were almost 2500 genes
so it's 1/10 of the genome and so we can
only focus with that
but of course 2500 genes is a large
number of genes we were liking because
when we were alive in this family that's
exactly when next-generation sequencing
was coming online now it's a normal
clinical test
all the back of that time you were some
of the first groups to use it and you
could do whole exome sequencing which
targets only the coding sequences of the
genes is one percent of the genome it's
fast cheap very easy to do and we expect
very large number of the disease
mutations are localized in the coding in
the coding regions so when you do
Edmonton exome you get for 30,000 to
sometimes a hundred thousand variants or
more this is just a normal variability
that we have as humans most of it is
common mostly to share with people from
the same as an exact rounds with your
family and so what we needed to do was
to identify a filtering strategy that
will allow us to identify the
disease-causing mutations so we focused
on the vision of a methodology because
that's where we predict that a mutation
is going to be and so early on those
twenty four hundred and eighty G then
the mutation has to be novel or rare
this is a very rare disorder so it
cannot be something that's floating
around the population and that could
cause disease in multiple people we also
expect it to be pathogenic which means
to disrupt the function of the protein
and so it can either be a missense
mutation and change it in the middle a
state or a truncating mutation which are
the causative style slightly change the
friendship something that will stop the
represent the full translation of the
protein and will generate a truncated
non-functional protein so we were very
shocked at the very very beginning
because this filtering approach reduced
another genes from almost twenty five
hundred to six in this particular in
this particular case and as we've been
doing this more and more with multiple
other families we find that on average
this approach reduces the number of
candidates to size which is very
exciting because it starts from up from
tens of thousands of genes that you can
really only get to a very small number
you can come on your hands of all the
limitations with six mutations that we
identified in the family once popped out
because it was in a glycosyl chapter if
there was a stop codon so it was a very
severe truncating mutation in a gene
that's called gtb/c to which at the time
we didn't even know what it did but
everywhere sequencing other families
with the same method we identified two
additional mutations another truncating
mutations these are homozygous which
means that both there are both
chromosomes and there of course was they
were identified two homozygosity another
truncating mutation early in the gene
and then a missense change which is very
very very conserved across all of the
different species so we were very
excited because we thought okay we have
to defend the mutation this is really a
great a great candidate and immediately
looking at the small number of genes
that we get and we decided that we
really needed validation plan that could
be used with medium to high throughput
to test all of these variants and if it
was the zebrafish came into play the
zebrafish is great for genetic screening
is really exploded in the past five
years basically as a tool for studying
genetic mutations because it develops
very quickly
and it has similar organs to us and so
you can that you can actually
recapitulate the disease sometimes in
the order of the day or two days is very
prominent eyes and muscle if one hour is
4,000 and 24 hours is this little larva
and you can see at the bottom of the
eyes the brain and detail where the
muscle is developing its fertilized
externally so you can take your eggs at
one cell stage so we only have one cell
before it divides and you can inject it
with multiple reagents to be able to
disrupt your gene of interest in this
case I'm showing you more saline or
oligonucleotides but of course now you
can also do crispers where you modify
the genome
of the very first cell to obtain a
mutant and using fish so what do we see
we see first of all you can start
looking at the embryo in the in the
Quarian the movement starts around 20
hours and oh sorry okay so it's not it's
not running movie so what I was going to
show you what I'm going to show you here
was a short movie where you see the
spontaneous movement of the zebrafish
into the Quarian the little zebrafish
will flip its tails i doing exactly the
same thing that baby's doing the warp is
activated in connecting its peripheral
nervous system to the muscles and
activating all of these processes and
it's moving and it's moving all over the
quarians we can train this particular
movement so we can trigger the head and
we can trace the tail and as you can see
here when you do the tracing it travels
it travels around quite a bit
we then can video the fish that have
been where the genes of interest for
muscular dystrophy a bit removed and I
will skip directly to the analysis and
instead what they do they'll move back
and forth they will not be able to
generate enough strength in their tail
to actually travel around and to do
their tail flips so that's already a
change in their motility on during
development what this does is actually
that when they're born as you can see as
you can see here they are born with a
curved tail this is very similar to what
happens to the human babies which are
born with what is called arthrogryposis
or contractures which means that
answering the wound
and their joints cannot move they're
actually born with joints stuck in
position and what examples you might
know that it's common with the clubfoot
where the ankle is permanently twisted
in this particular case we can actually
say like the little zebra pieces of club
tail so it's completely stuck in a
situation it cannot extend it in
addition to to that they also have very
severe losses for gt22 was removed
they have very severe defects in the
development of their head you can see
the retina is not fully fused and
developed in the eye of this little fish
the shape of their head is not normal
you can definitely see a edema and a
stroke where there is blood in the brain
so they were that they were clearly not
normal the issue is does this
recapitulate what we see with the
patients and so we started first of all
looking at the muscular dystrophy the
muscular dystrophy is one of the primary
diagnostic criteria for this disorder
where you see loss in this remarkable
constellation and so on the left here
you see the human biopsy with normal
distribution and indirect oscillation
and lamina so - and the loss of the
copulation and disruption laminate on
the left you see the fish muscle in the
fish lots of them extra cellular matrix
that you see distributed around the
myofibrils is actually distributed in
this line longitudinal line the green
eyes that you see here when we look at
this trophy and absence or kaiken and
you see that in the north and fish we're
due to deciduous be removed you have a
loss of both dystrophin and alpha mr.
baiken so it's very similar mechanisms
to the one very similar defense to the
one that we've seen the humans we were
also are really excited to see a similar
brain malformation because if you
prevent pigmentation you can
we see the three male arteries of the
ventricles in the brain of the fish and
three days for socialization so this is
just a three day old and we own that
stirred into a large russet starting to
swim this as you see in a creative
section here in the organization of the
brain the ventricle of the zebrafish
forms differently from the human
ventricle because it fuses at the top
and so instead of having this very
extreme extension that you see in the
human brain you see a compression of all
of the brain tissue towards the ventral
part of the fish but it's very similar
and we can basically see that they also
have hydrocephaly in addition we can
recapitulate the retinal deficits the
zebrafish retina is very same
organization as the human retina they
are very very good the acidity very well
in colors so they're similar to us in
that extent and they have pretty much
the same type of cells and nonlinear
organization one of the characteristics
of the new stage of the transformation
the optimum information is retinal
dysplasia so is the disruption in
activity retinal organization and you
can see here in the morph event again
disruptions of regular organization the
cells are much less compact even in the
ventral portion of the portion of the
retina so we're very excited because we
could recapitulate all of the human
phenotypes in the muscle in the brain
and in the eye then the great thing you
can do is reposition you can start doing
manipulations and so you can use the
human mRNA to see if you can rescue the
motion see inside why is this important
it's important to show that the genes
function is concerned across resolution
and so they are actually testing a
function that is through in the humans
and so what you see here we see that we
use the human GT dc2 to rescue the
phenotype in this fish but the other
thing that you can do
is really interesting is that you can
take your missense mutations because if
you have a track a limitation sometimes
it's inculcate a function of the protein
is interested but you can take a
missense mutation you can do the same
experiment and you can demonstrate that
that nuisance mutation completely remove
the function of the protein and this is
what we did with that misrepresentation
in CDC dc2 so it's a really cool model
also for studying mutation function so
this was this was great and we basically
started expanding this method and like
you try to use it in different ways and
so what was very exciting is that we
were actually also able to look at
families that were non conservative
because of course you will have access
to families from all over the world in
this particular case there were
unrelated parents from South Africa that
it had three children with Walker
Warburg syndrome when we look through
the exome of both of the children that
we have available
and what was amazing is that there was
only one gene that came out that was
inherited in one in one unit one
mutation from the mom one mutation from
the dad and having two mutations in the
kids and this gene was called v3 Galan -
if you're not a conservation expert this
name will not say anything for you but
if you are you become really excited
because it is a guide for transferase
and it is also which is also involved
with tobacco by calculation at the same
time we collaborated with other groups
for example Madonna University College
London identified additional families in
the same genes plus in different
families in the UK and so we basically
came up with a variety of mutations
across this gene causing the causing the
disorders so that was very exciting and
the D 3-gallon to morph into fish was
identical to the GDC - so the zebrafish
again confirmed that this is the
phenotype that that you can see
um this can also be used to study our
variability in other genes we looked at
what's called PO m'kay we have this one
family with a somewhat different
presentation they had Lindbergh's of
muscular dystrophy we should schedule
master degree which shows up a little
bit later with reduced intellectual
functioning there's differently from
most of our other patients they're still
alive they were ambulatory amusements
could like d'affaires and walk around in
their 20s suit was much less severe and
also a family with a child with Walker
Walker syndrome that very very severe
disorder and in both cases we identified
alleles in some case okay differently
from the other genes with the kinase and
I'll tell you in a second
what it does and what was interesting
was that family one had homozygous
stop mutation that basically removed the
entire kinase domain while steadily two
had two hundreds I guess mutations which
one was very very friendships than the
other one was later in this protein and
so we were wondering why the loss of the
entire kinase domain so that caused this
disorder was not as severe as this
particular case and so we developed the
Pompey Morphin so with the Marcelino to
look at the mountains of the fish this
is not as severe as the other district
anomaly fish that we have studied in the
past but we were able to show that you
can see in the in the central bar graph
in the fourth bar and we recap we've
made the mutation in this four lines
mRNA this early truncation and we
basically saw that it was complete loss
function but also it didn't generate any
gain of function when we transacted it
when they injected it on its own and so
this is really a complete loss of
function that points out that there can
be different phenotypes resulting from
complete loss of function
of all K and so that the
genotype-phenotype correlation is not
direct so what I told you so far is that
by using this approach of declaration
super-seriously professional edition we
were able to identify three new disease
genes that regulate that as a district
regular calculation from work of several
groups looking at the function of this
reason in particular from Quezon
Campbell University of Iowa people
identified the function of this protein
that actually showed that they are
necessary for labid inviting as I showed
you at the very beginning laminin is one
of the ligands in the official your
matrix binding to distribution
there is now very defined laminin
binding glycan combination and these
genes are critical for the formation of
that particular structure and so some of
the classical genes that are involved in
design kenapa these are 21 and 22 which
add the initial manners on its change
and then we found that 22 would add the
second sugar duty until the third sugar
on this x3 saccharide which is necessary
for london binding from k is predicted
to phosphorylate this initial mannose
and its structure has been resolved just
here showing that it's a non-traditional
kinase that can catalyze phosphorylation
of sugar
this event is really important for the
addition of this glycine which is very
constant very long complex disaccharide
that is important again for laminate
binding so we study know-how loss of the
trisaccharide causes water Warburg this
tri factor is called vaca river but how
the sidechain is involved in LG&E SPMD
and this is going to be something really
interesting that we and other groups
will continue
to work on in the future but now we have
all the zebrafish models and we're
collecting more and more mutations that
we can analyze in this model to be able
to see to be able to see what happens so
I'll just give you a sub this is an
intermediate summary that I'll spend the
last like 10 minutes telling you a news
story but basically what I told you so
far is that we can use homozygosity
mapping and whole exome sequencing in
cosine beta families very easily to
identify this is causing mutations in
these very rare and severe disorders
where you may need to focus on only one
family at a time always of sequencing
has shown to be very efficient even in
office under this unions as long as you
have multiple affected children and then
you can use the zebrafish and the method
of rapid validation for candidate
mutations and you can look at the
different phenotypes they're comparable
to the ones you see in the humans this
particular framework doesn't necessarily
just fit with each American operative
who's now being used across the world
for multiple different disorders and
nonlinear developmental disorders
because of the rapidity of using bags of
sequencing and the zebrafish
with this method we identifies disease
to be triggered respond K asking for
different analogies and now we're trying
to push this approach to tackle sporadic
cases and what I want to tell you in the
last few minutes is actually one story
where we did that where we started to
look at sporadic cases that had a
somewhat different phenotype somewhat
strange phenotype try to find new genes
for new these orders and these are two
more people in my table net colleagues
with the grad student and collude
mistress whose is petitions that have
are working really hard in this project
and have helped get it started so this
started from two families that we
from Italy it was one girl which had
short stature cataracts and intellectual
disability and one boy with short
stature brain atrophy and ID they were
not even that similar but because of the
extreme eternity without sequins
everybody and we are completely agnostic
on what the genetic cause for the
disease is going to be what we knew is
that both of them had dystrophic
features in their muscle and that both
of them had a disruption in the
consolation of district lichen and so if
you see the top with yesterday cervical
column the nice localization of the
district right hand around the Maya
fibers and then the complete disruption
in the patients which is not a loss
because we can see there is still
disturbing and present it just seemed to
be completely disorganized and maybe in
some cases trapped inside the inside the
cell but this cell was presented to us
as a distraction apathy and so when we
sequence these families we found maybe
three or four possible candidate genes
in each of them but those timing
patients in this gene that's called IMDB
5k the girl had a header had two
heterozygous mutations and the boy had
homozygous mutation in one of the same
alleles that the girl had so we have
basically three alleles in small 23 and
one in this other location so this was
interesting and it became even more
interesting when we started reading out
the bottom would be fine okay so I ended
the 5k is a phosphatase and so which
means it removes the phosphate but it's
a very different so it's a very
different gene from the ones that we've
been studying so far it's an inaugural
phosphatase and
which what it does it removes a
phosphate in position size on both tip 3
and
- so it would ask them Vista to industry
so you probably heard one of the most
famous inaudible phosphatases is p10 our
t10 has been involved in autism it's
involved in microcephaly and I think
it's like commonly discussed there's a
really strong regulator of the mTOR
pathway and so feedback is it 3
phosphatase int because k is a 5
phosphatase so it just removes to put
the phosphate at a different position on
the individual in our digital brain what
this do they regulate the slew of
pathways and of different processes
within the cell including active
regulation vesicular trafficking calcium
signaling several signaling processes
including and toward your skin trivia NF
Kappa B which lead to a variety of
changes and a function within within the
cell so this is definitely a really
important really important process and a
really important protein and other thing
that was really interesting to us is
that I under dislike K was originally
identified as skip skeletal muscle and
kidney enriched inaudible sausages so
skeletal muscle they're being the
operative word
it's very important in discussing
muscles were instantly processing an
insulin and response to insulin and then
activation of the m4 pathway downstream
of the cell signaling of influence
signaling so we were really interested
because we thought it was critical from
muscle development and we had no idea
what it could do in the brain the
problem is that we only had two cases
and so what we really wanted to do was
find more and this is where we went to
gene matcher so there's our entry page
and this is this URL register prints
websites this is an effort that all the
different genetic centers are running to
make scientists work together and to
help
scientists identify new cases there are
multiple data sharing websites that I
want to share with you there's beacon
network to global my g2 which is similar
to gene matcher and they've all been
connected into the matchmaker exchange
so the matchmaker exchange the huge
effort to basically connect all of these
websites that are collecting genetic
genetic and clinical information so that
both clinicians and geneticists can
search these websites for the genes of
interest and they can be connected to
each other and so the way gene matcher
works is that you're depressed
interested in gene everytime someone
else expresses interest in a gene you
receive an email that says this person
wants to know about I have to pee 5k you
want to talk to them and that's how you
connect to people also what I want to
bring up is that this is not just for
geneticists I've had basic scientists
like reach out to me about a MTP 5k
because they were working on that
particular protein and so if you're
working on a mechanism of disease or
you're even working on a basic mechanism
this is a great resource because you can
connect both the clinicians and the
geneticists they may be working on your
team of interest and you may find
something new about its function and you
may also be able to find great
collaborators as we did so through this
process we identified two additional
families that have mutations in int p5k
these mutations are distributed mostly
in the positive domain and in the ruffle
targeting or stitch domain they are all
incredibly concerned all the way to the
zebrafish and some of them are very very
strong so sorry conserved domain which
are critical for phosphatase function
when we tested the enzyme function in
collaboration resource swans group in
the UK we saw the DES mutations the most
of our mutations very severely reduced
and then functionally the mp5k
instability to our
phosphate from pick two to keep one
through genematcher we also identified
another group that has 12 additional
cases with AMD defect annotations with
four different alleles and what this led
to Alette actually two two back-to-back
publications looking at the function of
these genes that just came out this
month when we identified basically a new
syndrome
we showed the MVP 5k mutation causes
syndrome with short stature muscular
dystrophy intellectual disability and
congenital cataracts which could overlap
with the district analyses and also with
another known syndrome which is
marinesko storage organ and we have now
eight different mutations across two
groups that cause this disease so we are
very sure that this gene this gene is
responsible just a very quick analysis
of the zebrafish this was interesting
because identity psych-k is duplicated
in the zebrafish
the zebrafish underwent a duplication
and genomic duplication event which
caused several genes who now has two
copies so we knocked down and beside K a
B and a B in general we found defects in
the body head body legs head lengths and
I diameter all in a and a B together and
not in the B and one of the reasons for
this is that a is the most highly
expressed gene will be expressed a very
very low level this is normal as when
you have duplications usually what
happens is that one of the duplicated
copies is silenced so that you don't
have twice as much
andum function or the other game starts
doing something completely different but
in this case it looks like it it's
mostly silent that non and
non-functional and we're looking into
that
the muscle in the more sense was
disrupted we looked at the ultra
structure of the muscle and we saw the
interruption in the sarcomere disruption
in the mind
star which are those areas where you
have the connection between the
different uh different muscles different
muscles in the in where the
extracellular matrix deposits and the
difference in this disruption in the
triad which is where regulation of
contraction is controlled we have a
smaller head with disorganized eyes and
we also saw a disruption in crystalline
organization in the lens during
development which is similar to what
happens in congenital cataract so again
in this zebrafish model we were able to
recapitulate all of the characteristics
of the patients with the myopathy the
small brain the small body and the
ocular the ocular deficits so what we
really want to find out now is like how
the loss of a mystic red K caused the
disease we know that it's important for
a KTM toward signaling in the muscle so
that could also be important for the
brain and a continuum towards involved
in multiple neurodevelopmental disorders
and definitely cause cognitive deficits
the other thing that's interesting is
that skip scientific RK is important
it's actually transported from the ER to
the plasma membrane via 0p 78 PRP 7ea is
a chaperone that resides in the yard
controls protein trafficking this
translocation is critical for expect for
skips regulation signaling but also
fifth District Lycan is calculated
except for this regulator in the ER we
wonder whether this could be the origin
like this lacking of this interaction
could be the orange e for the disruption
in this relation expression and is
something that we're definitely
following up and so to conclude what I
told you what I told you today is that
they are near muscular disorders and
your developmental disorders affecting
brain function and development are very
genetically clinically heterogeneous but
that we can use these techniques to
really make gene identification much
faster when we can use next generation
sequencing and then an animal model like
the zebrafish which allows you to look
at differentiation from multiple organs
in people very quickly I also hope that
I convinced you that sherry genetical
clinical information has been going on
in our community and it's incredibly
important we would not have been able to
complete these last stories if we hadn't
met so many different groups through
gene matcher and through these matching
services and all started working
together to combine our patients who
combined our expertise and to push these
papers through publications on very
quickly and then the last point that I
want you to take away that yes mr. Mike
analogies are mostly caused by mutations
in lycosa transferases but this latest I
mp5k mutation identification latest the
possibility that there may be also
additional mechanisms that are possible
and so I want to thank everybody in my
lab and our wonderful collaborators the
sequencing centers that have helped us
with the sequencing and the
collaborative collaborators that have
provided the patients we working with I
thank the patient families and our
funding sources and I will take
questions
thank you for that informative
presentation dr. Mancini before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left with
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is how many genes do
you think we are still missing for the
remaining 50% of cases that's that's a
great question so so the problem is that
as you have seen we are focusing on the
coding regions and the vast majority of
what we're doing is in the exhilarating
the coding regions we are really not
considering yes so we're starting to
consider now non-coding and regulatory
mutations it seems that it's like 50%
threshold is very hard to break so we
keep finding new genes but they only
affect a very very small number of
patients so there is nothing that is
more common that we're missing we think
so insider
there are another 20 genes that cause
very very rare forms of the disease or
it's absolutely possible that the genes
we already know are responsible for a
large portion of the cases through
non-coding mutations that are either in
chronic or in the promoter or even
hamsters that regulates the function of
these genes and that really like this
understanding the non-coding genome is
really the next frontier and I think
it's going to be very interesting
thank you for our next question is the
zebra finch sensitive enough to model
disease variability ah yeah I think I
mean I think it's a good question it
doesn't it just definitely depends on
the acting and how well your rescue
works we have had a lot of success with
that with some leaves where we were
actually able to model moderate versus
severe presentation recapitulating that
in the zebrafish where we could show
that a mutation that causes a very
severe presentation and complete loss of
function causes a more severe phenotype
in the fish and a mutation that only
partially affects the function of the
protein can rescue to a certain extent
that completely depends on how good your
rescue is and how good your morpholino
your more freely noise thank you
our next question is are mo Felina
[Music]
oligonucleotides really the best
approach to model loss of function I
heard they have a lot of issues
Oh gran ah yeah so there's this a huge
discussion in the field on whether we
should use more Salinas at all I I
personally think that they get a bad rep
because people sometimes are not careful
on how they use more Philly knows you
have to be very careful some of them are
bad and you have to be able to
distinguish when more Salinas bad and
when it's main is having a specific
effect so when it when it's not what we
usually do you know we want to use this
that you want to use the lowest possible
concentration we want to make sure that
it's rescued by the human mRNA and that
this function is conserved and that the
chain that you're removing is actually
the gene you're interested in what we're
also doing in parallel we use crispers
and so I think nowadays you need to have
multiple validation methods to really
show that the phenotype that you're
getting is the correct one we are
certainly heartened by the fact that we
can recapitulate the human phenotype and
so that we have a specific set of
molecular changes that we see in the
human such as the loss of a calculation
that we also see the zebrafish causes
caused by our arm or cellino's but yeah
there is there is definitely a lot of
discussion in the field on which is the
best method to use and which is the most
valid
okay we have time for one more question
how would you recommend a cell
biologists use the matching websites
that you discussed yes that was very
cool because when I when I started
getting a request from from how biology
labs does ablute genetics I was like why
are you even on this website but but
then I realized it's actually a great
tool if you who are working on a gene
that you think is related to disease or
it's related to a gene the cause of
disease by demonstrating interest you
can be put in touch with other groups
for collaboration so now I'm actually
really I'm sorry to think more from the
aspect of the cell biology that we do in
the lab and start expressing interest to
a lot more to a lot more genes because
you can identify people you can work
with you can identify people identify
people that do particular biochemical or
biological tests that you want to use
and I think just in general is going to
speed up the process of discovery and
for us it was really transformative
because it brought a new tension that
had been identified for almost three
years where we really didn't know what
to do with those two patients to having
two publications in the range of like
four months because we all came together
at the same time we were all ready to
move forward any one's really excellent
I was a really excellent experience
I would like to once again thank dr.
Mancini for her presentation do you have
any final comments no I was like I would
like to thank the the crowd and
everybody for for the questions and for
listening so this was wonderful I'll
send a shout-out to dr. yalda tragedy
who really was my partner in crime for
this latest scientific taipei project
because i realized i didn't single her
out as i was going through this thing
very quickly but without collaborators
really we wouldn't be able to do
everything that we do thank you thank
you dr. Mancini today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June of 2017 you will receive an email
from Lavery saluting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye
you